- Good morning believe nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your
journey today's message
is be who you were born to be.
Over to you, Michael Jordan.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- [Michael] It's not about the shoes.
(light, peaceful piano music)
It's about knowing where you're going.
Not forgetting where you started.
(moves to stronger,
inspirational piano music)
It's about having the courage to fail.
Not breaking when you are broken.
Taking everything you've been given
and making something better.
It's about work
before glory.
And what's inside of you.
It's doing what they say you can't.
It's not about the shoes, it's
about what you do in them.
It's about being
who you were born to be.
- Michael Jordan did
what he was born to do.
He found what he was born to do
and the unique thing
about it was he found it
and then he actually took action on it
and he worked hard at it.
It wasn't just, "I'm
naturally gifted at this,
"and so I can coast and
achieve some kind of results."
He took the work to find the
thing that he was great at
and he put in the effort
consistently to become
an icon at his chosen profession.
And it's great and we look up to him
and I use Michael Jordan as an
example in a lot of my videos
and he is perhaps the
greatest basketball player
of all time.
But you are no less an icon,
you are no less great at something.
I believe that we all have
Michael Jordan level talent
at something and that's
what you need to find.
And you either haven't
found it yet because
you haven't done enough exploring to find
the thing that you're great at,
or you haven't put in the effort to get
really, really good at it.
You have this thing that
you have potential to be
the Michael Jordan of in your field
and you're kind of coasting on it,
you're not putting in the work,
you're not practicing your job shot
and your free throws
and getting to the gym,
whatever that equivalent
is in your industry.
I like to say that Michael Jordan is not
the greatest basketball player
of all time as an example.
And they say the greatest
basketball player of all time
was a manager at Starbucks.
Because that person, that guy at Starbucks
who's a manager now,
should have played
basketball but he either
never picked up a ball,
he never explored enough
to find out what he was great
at, or he never practiced.
And I think if you
don't know what you have
Michael Jordan level talent at,
then you need to explore.
So often we discount things
that could immensely serve
us without even trying.
Because it goes against our culture,
it goes against how we,
you know what was on
our radar at the start.
Like I never thought I was
going to be an entrepreneur.
I just didn't have
entrepreneurs in my family,
we didn't talk about
entrepreneurship growing up.
It wasn't something that
was ever on my radar.
And so I never thought I was
going to be an entrepreneur.
And I had the good fortune to
connect with two entrepreneurs
at the university
and join their business
and be an owner in that
and learn about entrepreneurship.
Even though I had all these entrepreneur
tendencies growing up.
And I would be probably
working at some bank
and hating my job if I didn't go down
that entrepreneurial path.
I would be the
manager at Starbucks instead
of being the entrepreneur
that I want to be.
And so if you don't know
what you are great at,
you don't know what you have
that genius level talent at
then you need to go and
start to explore, try stuff!
Say yes, when somebody
invites you to something,
say yes and go do it!
Instead of coming up with all the reasons
why it's never going to work out,
all the reasons why that
it's not a good fit for you,
just say yes and try it.
How many times have you
discounted something
in your head, 'cause you've
run through the analysis
without ever actually taking action
and saying yes to something.
So if you're insanely
happy, life is amazing,
you have the career you
want and the life you want
the friends you want
and the family you want,
everything is amazing great,
you don't have to do any of this.
Keep doing what you're doing,
'cause life is amazing.
But if you're not happy,
if you haven't found the
thing that you love yet,
if your relationship isn't perfect
and your business isn't perfect then
you are daily unhappy, don't
sit there and complain,
and don't sit there and just dismiss ideas
that can help you grow,
because it might be
scary or new and foreign
or different to you.
Just say yes and try it.
Don't be that manager at Starbucks
who never picked up the basketball
and could have been the
greatest basketball player
of all time.
Be Michael Jordan.
Explore.
(digital swish)
Say yes.
Try it.
See if it makes you come alive.
If it does do it again, if not stop it
and go do something else.
You have Michael Jordan
level talent at something.
And I want you to find it.
(digital swoosh)
So the question of the day today is,
(sighs) do you know what
you have Michael Jordan
level talent at?
And if you do, what is it?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
Also if you leave a
comment within the first
couple hours of this video
you have a good chance
of winning one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Riccardo Garegnani,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really, really means
a lot to me man and I hope
you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Espresso.
♫ I wake every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter clicking)
- Nothing fails like success.
You're successful, maybe
it's in your health,
maybe it's in your finances,
maybe it's in your career,
maybe it's in your family life.
Maybe it's in the way that
you show up in the world.
Awesome!
You're in a really
vulnerable place right now.
It is one thing to be successful,
it is another thing to sustain success
over the coming decades.
Is that not a powerful idea?
I mean, let's go to the
entertainment industry.
It's very hard to be a one hit wonder,
let's not knock a one hit wonder.
But it's even harder to
become an iconic rock band
or hip hop band.
Let's go to the arts.
It is very hard to come up with
your Sistine Chapel, got it.
It is even harder to
become a Michael Angelo.
So are you playing the short game?
Or are you playing the long game?
This is rule number two, you
know or lesson number two
that life has taught me.
Play the long game.
Aim for legendary.
Don't just say I want to be world class
in my dominant pursuit for
a little window of time.
I want to have the guts and the grit
and the acumen and the
mindset and the capability
and the commitment to
create enduring success.
And that's why I say
nothing fails like success.
You look at the restaurant that is hot
in your neighborhood right now.
They're on the path to
obsolescence if they're
not really careful.
Sure, they went from a
little neighborhood shop
that made beautiful pasta,
that had great service,
that had the owner on the
floor shaking your hand,
getting to know your name.
Then they got written up in the magazines
and then they got interviewed
and then word of mouth
spread like wildfire and what happened?
They became arrogant.
You see success can be so toxic.
And it happens, it is such
a pull on every human being.
It just plays with your mind.
And you literally shift
from humility to arrogance.
You shift from humility to arrogance
and once the arrogance
sets in in a mindset
it starts to populate every
other person on the team,
every other person in the culture,
every other person in the community.
And it is a very short fall
from success to irrelevance.
So lesson number two is
nothing fails like success
as you become more successful,
become more humble.
As you become more
successful, work even harder.
successful, care even more
about your product.
As you become more
successful, learn even more.
I invite you when you are
the titan of your industry
be sitting in the room with 18 year olds
beginning their game.
When you are the,
the icon of your field,
be the person who is up,
not at five o'clock anymore,
let's play at four o'clock, reading,
listening to the podcast,
writing in your journal,
setting your goals,
focusing on your intentions.
As you become more
successful, be more humble.
As you become more successful,
be even more punctual.
become even more passionate.
As you become older, become even younger.
Yesterday I was walking on the street
and I met this man in his 80s.
He said, "Robin I finally retired."
He's probably close to 90.
And he is
a legendary clothier in
the country that I live in.
And he just retired.
And he started his shop,
which is now an empire, in 1954.
So I don't know what that is,
but that is decades
and decades and decades
and decades and he did not want to retire.
He just retired, but he is still on fire
to do amazing things.
Age is just a number,
do not let an old person
into your body, nothing
fails like success.
- I started actually writing
a science fiction novel
that had been an idea I'd
been playing with a long time,
a book called Avalon.
And I was working on Avalon
and it was coming pretty well.
And suddenly the first chapter of
Game of Thrones came to me.
Where they find the dire wolf pups.
(water sploshing)
- It's freak.
- It's a dire wolf.
- I know it wasn't a part
of the science fiction
novel I was writing, this was
clearly a fantasy, medieval.
Had these,
wolves and this large family.
I'd been reading a lot
of historical fiction
and it might have been
in the back of my mind.
But suddenly it all gelled and I wrote
and I wrote that chapter
in like two or three days.
It just came to pour out of me.
- Lord Stark.
Here are five pups.
(pups squealing)
One for each of the Stark children.
The dire wolf is the sigil of your house.
They were meant to have them.
- You will train them yourselves.
You'll feed them yourselves.
(metal scrapes)
And if they die, you'll
bury them yourselves.
- When I did return to books.
I said to myself, "Okay,
"I've had many things option
they never make them."
I've done pilots and TV
shows, tried to keep them
within budget and produceable
and they never make that.
I'm tired of playing that game.
You know I have a big imagination,
I have an epic story I want to tell.
I'm going to make it as
big as my imagination,
I'm going to have all the
castles and battles I want,
I'm going to have hundreds of characters,
'cause the real world
is complex and I want my
fictional world to be complex, too,
not as a kind of simplified thing.
I want to have giant
battles, I want to have
incredible castles that
each one is distinct from the other
that people will remember for all time.
I want to have dragons and dire wolves
and mammoths and a wall of
ice that's 700 feet tall.
I want something huge and epic that can
stand up there with Tolkien.
(epic orchestral music)